los pesos de once bebés diferentes se
registran en la gráfica de línea
siguiente podemos verlo tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 puntos cada uno
representa el peso de un bebé distinto
cada peso se redondeó al 1 octavo de
kilogramo más cercano
muy bien y después nos preguntan cuál es
la diferencia en peso entre los dos
bebés más pesados pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la respuesta antes de
que lo trabajemos juntos bueno primero
pensemos en cuáles son los dos bebés más
pesados este punto que tenemos acá
representa el peso del bebé más pesado
cuál es su peso veamos
su peso es justo este cuál es ese valor
o cuál es ese peso bueno esta es la
marca que representa el 9 y esta otra al
10 y la distancia la tenemos dividida en
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 secciones iguales así
que cada marca representa un octavo
entonces este es 9
12 octavos esto es nueve y dos octavos y
bueno otra forma de pensarlo es que dos
octavos es lo mismo que un cuarto ya que
podemos pensar esto mismo como una dos
tres cuatro secciones iguales así que
esto también es nueve y un cuarto del
camino a diez esto es lo mismo que nueve
kilogramos y un cuarto ahora cuál es el
segundo bebé más pesado porque recuerda
nos piden la diferencia entre los dos
bebés más pesados bueno el segundo bebé
más pesado está justo aquí y sabemos que
pesa ocho kilogramos y medio entonces lo
que realmente necesitamos hacer es
encontrar la diferencia entre nueve y
dos octavos o nueve y un cuarto y 8 y un
medio justo aquí bueno podemos
establecer esto como una fracción
tenemos nueve y un cuarto menos ocho y
un medio
y de hecho podemos usar estas escalas de
medida en la recta numérica para
ayudarnos a encontrar esta resta la
diferencia es esta longitud de aquí y
podemos pensar en términos de octavos ya
que cada una de estas marcas es un
octavo tenemos un octavo dos octavos
tres octavos cuatro octavos cinco
octavos y seis octavos también podemos
pensarlo en términos de cuartos
tenemos un cuarto dos cuartos y tres
cuartos así que esto es igual a tres
cuartos así que cuál es la diferencia en
peso entre los dos bebés más pesados
bueno son tres cuartos de kilogramo y
hemos terminado